this video is brought to you by Wix
what's the first thing that comes to
mind when you think of the films of
Quentin Tarantino is it Travolta having
a legendary comeback while wearing one
of the most stylish wigs of all time or
PJ Novak leaving his temp job at
dunder-mifflin to go hunt Nazis or is it
just an inspiring cacophony of Samuel
Jackson yelling the f-word about
whatever you pictured it wasn't a
comprehensive subversion of the logic of
slavery and that's why today we're
talking about Django Unchained a movie
that has all the typical Tarantino
hallmarks that we love while also giving
us an incredibly clever nuanced and dare
we say fun criticism of slavery so join
us as we break down the fastest and
flyest gun in the West in this wisecrack
addition on Django Unchained subverting
the logic of slavery but Before we jump
in want to give a shout out to our
sponsors over at Wix as I mentioned
before I used weeks to create a free
professional-looking website to promote
my voiceover work people always told me
I had a good voice for that kind of
stuff but I never really thought of
myself as a performer but after doing
all these wisecrack videos I decided to
use Wix to see if I could take something
I really like doing and turn it into
something legit all I had to do was tell
the interface my experience with
creating a website pick a design I like
then boom now my voice is profitable no
matter what you need a website for Wix
will give you the ability to take that
passion skill or business to the next
level so head to Wix calm slash
wisecrack to easily get started for free
and now back to the show all right guys
a quick recap is an order django
unchained follows a captured runaway
slave Jango who gets rescued and taken
under the wing of genteel German bounty
hunter King Schultz after teaching him
his craft and making some good money in
the process
Schultz accompanies Jango on a mission
to rescue his wife from Hilda from one
of the most vile villains in recent
cinema plantation owner Calvin Candie
now one way to make an anti-slavery
movie is to make revenge porn about a
former slave burning down a southern
plantation so yeah check but beneath the
classic Tarantino isms Django provides
three far more subtle commentaries on
slavery part one
cover ugly with civilization
surprisingly Jenko and chain offers a
purpose to language beyond a vehicle in
which one crams as many as possible man
I'm telling you I don't can I'm giving
you a reason
that's because from the perspective of
slavers like Big Daddy and Calvin Candie
white bodies represent culture and
civilization while black bodies are seen
as uncivilized and incapable of proper
use of language and appreciation of
culture enter Schultz this eloquent
German speaks English as a second
language so well that it confounds the
native speaking slavers he needs to have
a sense of showmanship showmanship yes
and well let's just say it's not his
accent so what I wish to parlay worthy
of its big English his mastery of
English vocabulary confuses those around
him multiple times my good man I'm
simply trying to ascertain a gamer's
goddamnit meanwhile his rhetorical
skills allow him to talk circles around
these simpletons of the American South
but I'm willing to wager this man was
elected sheriff some time in the past
two years
Schultz disrupts the racist binary we
just discussed by making these
self-satisfied southerners look wildly
uncivilized by comparison he's basically
an emblem of the mythical European
civilization that American men of means
built their plantations on and he's the
walking reminder that these self-styled
men of culture are well they're foolish
the idea that slaves were incapable of
proper language goes way back to
Aristotle for Aristotle humans differed
from animals based on logos a Greek word
meaning both speech and reason by
contrast my dog woody can only
communicate by phone oohs the yapping
and barking that can only communicate
fear displeasure and hunger as well as
other basic instincts more importantly
Aristotle used this to justify slavery
in Greece because they were in his mind
only capable of receiving and
understanding logos but not possessing
it in other words slaves weren't capable
of proper speech and the reason that
came with it and not surprisingly this
language based justification for slavery
and racism just never died Jane
so takes this dichotomy and flips it
some of the cruelest slavers mumbles so
incoherently that they make post Malone
sound articulate
contrast that would be clearly
intelligible slaves they walked us from
the Greenville auction and he rolled in
on a horse with the white man at every
opportunity film contrasts how Schultz
treats slaves with how every other white
person does unlike his peers Schultz
uses the honorific frow line when
talking to broom-hilda instead of the
n-word for the candy however demands the
French honorific Monsieur as a sign of
respect and he prefers Monsieur Candie
to mr. candy she's just lucky and
profound he doesn't speak French don't
speak French to him it'll embarrass him
whereas Schultz uses titles as a form of
voluntary respect candy uses them as
mandatory submission now we can see a
similar dynamic with the way that the
film uses beer early in the film Schulz
buys well steals Django a beer and this
seems to symbolize the transition from a
free man and slave relationship to a
couple of co-workers having a cold one
after a long day's work later in the
phone we see candy order of beer for one
of his fighters after a victory but this
exchange doesn't have the same Cheers s5
instead Candy's using beer as a sick
sort of reward for an enslaved man
forced to literally murder another man
for the enjoyment of two slave owners
one beer represents shared humanity
while the other represents cold-blooded
savagery you enjoy that boy now at the
same time even the multilingual European
man of culture isn't all that civilized
for one he's a bounty hunter who
literally kills people for a job the way
the slave trade deals in human lives
from cash a bounty hunter deals in
corpses and while he isn't a fan of
owning people he still buys Django for
his own self-interest and more or less
forces him into helping him out on one
hand I despise slavery on the other hand
I need your help if you're not in a
position to refuse all the better though
unlike the others he at least
acknowledges that this isn't a moral act
just a pragmatic one we see the contrast
between Schultz and the faux civilized
white Southerners at its peak once were
introduced to Calvin
I mean Monsieur Candie a title he
demands even though he doesn't speak or
understand French oh and he has the hots
for his sister candy even tries to show
off his German to Schultz but well he
doesn't quite nail it
Oh ever be going to BA fooling the BA oh
and while Schultz manages to play his
part while letting candy look like a
jackass he reaches his boiling point
when a woman starts playing Beethoven on
the harp I'm having a flashback about
what he'd seen earlier Schultz can no
longer deal with having a beautiful
product of his culture appropriated by
people who are truly savages and while
we're on the topic of some of Europe's
most notable exports of the colonies
it's worth mentioning how the Christian
Bible the book meant to signify proper
European religion was used to justify
slavery we see this in action when
Django is on his first bounty job at Big
Daddies plantation and comes upon one of
the brittle brothers literally quoting
the Bible while preparing to whip a
slave the Lord said to feared not only
this he has a page of the Bible pinned
to his shirt over his heart which serves
as a great target for Jengo to put a
bullet through
it's as if Jenko shot points out the
bloody hypocrisy of using Christianity
to justify savagery like the way you
died maybe you couldn't recognize the
verse brutal was reciting but it was
Genesis 9 verse 2 when God gives mankind
power over all the beasts birds fish etc
a perfect justification for slavery if
you think that slaves are less than
human part two using the symbols of
slavery to make slavery looks stupid
while language and culture are the most
obvious ways in which the film is on
slavery we can also see how it uses
everything from fashion to music to
iconography to further flip the logic of
slavery on its head one way to
understand what Tarantino is doing is to
consider Joseph sink a leader of the
Amistad rebellion sink a led a revolt in
which a group of illegally purchased
slaves took control the Amistad back
from their Spanish captors sink a and
his comrades became surprising folk
heroes even as they fought charges of
mutiny
and murder now importantly sink' was
portrayed in media in the style and
fashion of a noble from the culture that
enslaved him in one newspaper he was
sketched in Buccaneers clothes striking
a gallant pose with a cane knife he used
to murder his captors historian Marcus
Redeker describes this depiction and
others as egalitarian and subversive
meanwhile abolitionists accused the
Spanish slavers as being savage pirates
we see something similar happened movie
when Schultz gives Django a makeover and
he comes out dressed like one of the
three musketeers you mean you wanna but
this isn't just the setup for a joke
Django's attire is deliberately abrasive
for anyone who would reserve such an
outfit for a white civilized man of
culture this and Django's horseback
riding and activity historically
associated with the well-to-do draws ire
or surprise from everyone around him and
of course in one of the film's final
scenes
Jenko takes out stephen's knees and
leaves em in a plantation shaped powder
keg on a horse while wearing Tandy's
clothes
Jenko x' aesthetic choices in some ways
resemble what theorist Hosea Stefan
Munoz called dis identification for
Munoz this identification is a strategy
of acting against a dominant ideology
that does not simply try to escape it or
assimilate within it rather one takes
the cultural logic of say slavery and
mangles its symbols from within
Django does not Don the attire of a
southern aristocrat to become one but
rather to abuse the very notion of the
southern gentleman we see a similar
logic in the work of artists Kehinde
Wiley who would paint Harlem residents
in the style of classic European art
Tarantino also plays with the soundtrack
to emphasize how Django flipped the
script on all types of cultural
expectations and uses what might seem
out of sync with a Western set in the
mid 19th century rap music
[Music]
but this choice makes perfect sense when
we consider that rap music has long been
used by those in positions of racial and
economic inequality to call on people to
as Public Enemy so beautifully put it
with this power often being the type of
systematic white supremacy rooted in the
history of American slavery
rap music has often been used to
fantasize about both changing one's
circumstances and seeking revenge for
this injustice along the way so it makes
sense that the song that Rick Ross and
Jamie Foxx wrote for this film 100 black
coffins has lyrics like so it seems like
a weird juxtaposition of genre and
soundtrack ends up being the perfect way
to highlight Django's journey of seeking
power and revenge under conditions of
oppression now to move from rap to opera
and no we're not talking about Hamilton
music is also used by Schultz to give
context to Django's journey to save his
wife
using regard Wagner's twilight of the
gods the fourth and final opera in his
the ring of the Nibelungen
interprets Django's attempt to rescue
from hilda in a way that makes Django
the Siegfried of his own story of
revenge Plus when a German meets a
real-life secret that's kind of a big
deal
as a German I'm obliged to help you in
your quest to rescue your beloved
Brunhilde Fockers opera can also be read
by the lens of his friend than enemy or
friend enemy friedrich nietzsche whose
twilight of the idols is a nod to
vogner's to highlight of the gods it's
not a stretch to say that vogner
Siegfried can be read as a Nietzschean
uber wedge one who responds to a
nihilistic lack of values by powerfully
creating new ones
so if Django is the Siegfried of the
film he is also a sort of ubermensch who
responds to the nihilist values of
slavery and white supremacy not with two
rational appeals to reform and dialogue
but by both metaphorically and literally
burning the whole damn thing to the
much like how the whole world burns down
to start anew for vogner and Django
Unchained the fiery destruction of
Candyland can be seen as a metaphorical
call for the destruction of the
institution of slavery in general it's
also highly unlikely that the guy who
made inglorious basterds isn't also
aware that vogner's Ring cycle was
basically the soundtrack for German
nationalism one cannot understand
National Socialism
[Music]
who does not understand Gardner so he's
using a narrative once appropriated by
the Nazis to support white supremacy to
tell a slavery revenge narrative that
destroys white supremacy not bad and in
one final act of symbolic subversion
Tarantino uses the Western to frame this
slave revenge fantasy and in case you
haven't seen many westerns they usually
consist of strong-jawed white dudes like
John Wayne killing off villainized
Native Americans while making brothel
workers swoon in Django Unchained the
white cowboy types are instead taken out
by a freed slave a subject largely
ignored in the Western Canada part three
acting out of slavery the final way we
can consider how slavery is subverted in
the film will bring pride to the heart
of all the theatre kids out there as
it's a consideration of the role of
acting and don't worry we're not talking
about how Leo should have won Oscar the
type of acting we're talking about is
related to the agency of individuals
there's a ton of academic debate about
the question of agency in slavery while
some imagine that slaves had their
humanity stripped away so fully that
they were completely lacking in any
agency and autonomy others explore the
kinds of freedom slaves were able to
exert there are tons of historical
examples of small or big action slaves
took in the name of resistance work
slowdowns arson straight-up murder etc
but of course the retaliations for these
acts of rebellion were so horrific that
many would have been justifiably
dissuaded from these acts of freedom in
Django Unchained acting is the primary
means by which Django has agency we see
this as Schulz prepares Django for their
mission to trick candy and save from
Hilda you'll be playing a character and
of course Django even has a wardrobe for
this character as we previously
mentioned we see janko's agency
expressed five decisions he makes while
acting out this role he's put in a
position to both berate other slaves
lash out at Candy's crew and even sit by
approvingly as a runaway slave is ripped
apart by dogs it's important to note
here that janko's decisions are neither
good or bad but rather the decisions he
gets to make within the scope of the
limited agency he's granted he doesn't
choose to treat candy slaves poorly out
of hatred but out of the necessity of
his own survival
this acting range comes in handy later
when Jenko has to outsmart a gang of
Australians to regain his freedom and
complete his mission he plays a part and
even uses props I've got the hand being
right in my pocket if you let me get get
it in to put on such a convincing
performance that the Aussies literally
hand him a gun but maybe the most
striking example of agency for acting is
Kandi's head house slaves Stephen now
Stephen really really hates Django like
a lot and this is likely a hatred born
of envy as while Stephen has worked his
ass off to become as powerful as
possible within the system of slavery
Django has gained freedom through
breaking out of that system altogether
but one thing they do have in common is
their shared employment of the Dramatic
Arts for personal gain Stephen has
performed his way out of the harsh labor
of the fields and into the relative
comfort of Candy's home and has even
gotten to the point where he can snap
back and disagree with his master and
like a new boyfriend trying too hard to
impress their parents around the
holidays Stephen laughs way too hard at
candy stupid jokes
well hell I can't imagine two weeks and
boast but unlike an insecure boyfriend
Stephen knows exactly what he's doing
and he uses this performed laughter to
gain trust and influence and this
influence is on full display when it's
Stephen not candy who realizes that
Schulz and Jenko have been playing them
the whole time dang hear from the
muscle-bound Jimmy
hey yeah for that good Stephen is a
student of nonverbal acting as well
performing a fake live which
necessitates a fake cane so that he
appears physically weak this disarms any
suspicion anyone might have about
Stephen being skilled or powerful while
Stephen is definitely a sort of villain
as even Django treats him to the same
fate as the white slavers it's important
to see this villainy in the larger
context is Stephen a bad dude who served
the interest of his white master over
those of the fellow slaves absolutely
but did he have any other way to get
some sort of freedom under the
conditions of slavery probably
and for all we know Stephen never had
the luxury of a fake German dentist
showing up to free him and teach him how
to shoot his way to freedom
Stephen is simply trying to manifest his
own power playing the cards he was dealt
and those cards truly suck so there you
have it a movie that you might have
dismissed as Tarantino's irreverent
attempt to make a slavery Western is in
fact one of the sharpest criticisms of
slavery and of white supremacy in recent
cinema and most importantly it answers
the all-important question what would it
be like to see a young Jonah Hill play a
member of a pre KKK hate group wearing
poorly cutout sheets on their heads as
they ride horses thanks for watching
guys and if you want to build your own
website for free check out Wix using the
links in the description and as always
peace
[Music]